[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation I am very
excited to be watching this with Johnny
Boy over here who I know is as an
Enthusiast I am for he even brought his
Blu signed Blu-ray to
demonstrate sign W this smudge is Edgar
right smudge smug is what I would say
ladies and gentlemen we're going to
watch Scott PM takes off I haven't even
seen the trailer for this but I heard
original cast is returning animated to
look a little bit more apt to its comic
book property I cannot wait to see
what's going on people go ahead leave a
like like that button subscribe and
click that notification Bell cuz you
best bet that we are going to be
covering the rest of this series also if
you did not catch my movie reaction that
did right here on this channel that is
up here on this channel that's the
sentence and as always full length rtion
watch Longs where you syn up with your
own copy available for our super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page John
and Greg that's us cover several things
exclusively over there with highlights
and watch alongs included with this
being the first episode though this is
made public the watch along for everyone
so if you want to get a taste of what
that's like go ahead check it out Link
in the description box all righty guys
let's get our groove
on o la la
okay
cool that's what I like to
see
nice it's like an authentic anime
op this is so exciting yeah that's cool
to see it in the actual with the
combination of both I love that this
property has a very inclusive you know
love of both versions they said they
wouldn't do it like if they couldn't get
everybody ett said on Twitter go in
blind and what we're doing doing just
that written by Brian Leo M it's a manga
I guess you you would call it that yeah
it's presented in that
style the dream
world the sands of
time that's neat
I'm so whoa alone alone precious little
life here she come wow there's such a
vision to this whoa
Yes W the scope on these shots my God
Ramona Flowers the girl of my dreams
it's time to wake up dude
wow what a
trip I had a dream about that girl again
he just woke
[Music]
up so specific when are you getting your
own place anime angles could you at
least get your own
stuff I have a
stuff Wallace looks kind of like asro
boy oo can I have some some of my wow
what a great reversal so leave I was
just about to
anyway I love how it feels like a
classic dub anime Toronto Canada not too
long ago who's the voice this
time oh I'm excited to see how the music
visuals are brought to life
we hey
hey that's right the movie had the
opening credits with
this
Steven I wonder who's on the music this
time more on that
later SL
Bas oh it looks like 3D want to do it
again let's do it again it's cool how
they're doing the focus like how they're
representing the depth of field with the
different lines in
animation it's interesting because it's
a kinetic world but because it's a show
is actually able to Pace itself slower
yeah I know sort of my girlfriend Scott
your life is so
interesting thanks Kim great camera work
that was
sarcasm it's okay I fell for it
too
Scott seems more optimistic little less
listless and
depressed gorill of beard
dreams unknown unkknown she might be
real
POV
hey hi
you know Sonic the
Hedgehog so wide ey there were two
different Sonic cartoons airing at the
same time one was dark and dramatic the
other was a hilarious comedy about chili
dogs just staring off at space the same
guy playing two different versions of
the same
guy that's a meta [__] maybe you didn't
watch cartoons or or you're not into
chili dogs oh I mostly watched older
stuff when I was a kid Columbo reruns
reruns cool got
it did you just ask me if I was real uh
no I was talking to someone else
Bye accentuated by the robotic sound
effect there were no plus ones everyone
here is someone I invited personally she
think Scott sucks
so do you know this one girl with hair
like this Ramona Flowers she's from New
York City the big app his eyes are just
tiling she's single got a job delivering
DVDs for Netflix
DVDs not much longer I forbid you from
dating her Scott Pilgrim cool thanks
Julie
[Laughter]
bye Wallace quick what movie should I
rent yes something starring a hot
guy oh there's got to be a Netflix genre
for hot guys Lucas Lee best chest in the
business who Chris P uh Chris P yeah oh
the game is over too it's over a second
time
Evans took me forever to get there how
long could it
take So Meta Netflix they were pretty
fast back in the day oh this must be at
the
beginning wow actually experiencing the
passage of
[Music]
time Sonic
guy Wallace Wells Scott Pilgrim Wallace
is my cool gay
roommate so like a sugar daddy situation
yes sugar
what enjoy your DVD Mr
Wells bit with a crow are you the person
in my dreams I thought we went over this
already he actually seems like so much
more innocent there's just a really
convenient Subspace Highway running
through your head it's like 3 miles in
seconds space Subways totally I get it
anyway want to go out sometime oh could
be a lowkey team up Canada and America
joining
forces what do you think huh actually
feeling the romance more too here I like
the sort of ethereal chill Wave Music
feels sweeter it's probably cuz all
those focus on knives Chow prior yes and
now she's in high school what's with the
X
anyway oh this X-Men one of us went to
Professor Xavier's School for gifted
youngsters and one of us did not yeah is
that a Sonic thing is it Sonic
no his eyes are smaller you don't have
the same fandoms why' you moved to
Toronto well I got the job delivering
DVDs for Netflix and Gideon always said
Toronto was one of the great cities
Gideon what a very specific job yes what
do you do well my last job is a really
long story filled with size how slow the
snow falls we don't have to talk about
our pasts it's my least favorite subject
God look at the textures too I love how
they actually look like kids but they
got these adult voices yeah in True
Hollywood fashion I grew up in the
mountains man did you do a lot of skiing
no not really yeah it's true their
voices are lower than in the
movie
uhoh oh we're breaking perspective man
dark bring me Matthew
Patel the game has
begun
o
that's a change yeah or more accurate to
its original material I don't
know this really picked up freezing Rona
I can't see
you there should be a door around here
whoa yes into the cosmos oh what a great
transition to her
eyes whoa good thing this wasn't a real
date otherwise it would qualify as a
major
disaster I'll make us some
tea sleepy time you look like you're
dying even though their voices are older
it still matches so perfectly with the
animation counterparts even though they
don't look like they're liveaction coun
just shows how perfectly cast they are
and their chemistry playing off each
other even just in
voice yes that's what I tune in for ah
sorry I'm just cold and
innocent does this help oh oh I'm cold
too
oh oh leveling up and up and up and
up Sparks uhhuh achievement unlocked
were you just going to bring the blanket
from your
bed maybe we could both get under it
while it's on the bed
I changed my
mind from what to what I'm not going to
send you home in a snowstorm or anything
you can sleep in my bed oh I reserve the
right to change my mind about the sex
later it's like a no warish feel now
fatal and it's much more like straight
about these things I really love the
tone of you sent for me oh yeah I did
cool it's like sabber puny thanks for
creating this league it's pretty
concept yes it is it seems our dear
Ramona has a new Suitor it's really
happening who is he oh Scott Pilgrim
awesome 23 years old wow jobless
hopeless he's in an indie band of
subjective quality hey hey that's great
they've been on one date but he's
currently sleeping in her bed that
bastard Scott Pilgrim is dating a high
schooler uh uhoh wait I I'm sorry
interesting way to present it they did
hold hands once okay does Ramona know
still odd what's his fight experience
he's been described as quote the best
fighter in the province unot by who I'll
relish this Victory Ramona's new guy's
going to wish he was never born oh wow
is this fun because of me because I'm
going to kill him and then he'll be dead
is the final few days of his precious
little life
yep what time is it not quite 8 a.m. I
have to work I really feel like this is
excellently executed in such a way where
you don't need to have seen the movie or
the comics or you could just be a brand
newcomer either way you were first
introduced to this world it'll make you
appreciate it I like the restructuring
it hits on a completely different way my
band has a show tonight you have a band
uh oh we're terrible please
come
900 p.m. the rocket I'll be there
uhoh and you know who else going to be
there honest sees oh no you need to
break up with your fake high school
girlfriend do I have to I
mean knives is an angel you need to end
it immediately knives is an angel I
challenge you to a blah blah blah
something about fighting
[Music]
League of evil
AES more like a league of B
[Music]
ring rocket
rocket
whoa lowkey kind of like the DARE video
I am 16 kinds of pump to see sex bomb
tonight I feel so excited I might
actually pass out oh God boy sure seems
like nobody delivered crushing news to
you
today you're better than him just know
that okay better than
who these like 3D holographic effects
are so interesting
yeah eyes are literally popping out of
its so I I have to go oh nice
perspective the opening band pulled out
they flaked crashing employ flaked uhoh
you can't call A Band Crash crash is a
cold classic car crash sex film shot
right here in
Toronto coronin BG if we suck then the
audience won't like us they'll think we
[Laughter]
suck this delivery is great there's only
one way to find out if we suck and
that's by playing just open for
yourselves you know I love the movie but
I actually feel like everyone's more
likable already yeah and everyone's yeah
got just a little bit more of an
approachability or something that's a
great would have put it I'm kind of
seeing someone in the band that's
[Music]
crazy I am too who are you dating in the
band
[Music]
yep I think it helps too they actually
look like
kids oh
Mr Pilgrim and the
boys
awesome he's so dreamy why are we
fighting aren't you Scott Pilgrim
depends who's asking it
is Matthew Patel Ramona's first evil
ex-boyfriend uh-oh didn't you read my
letter kind of I hand delivered it
during a blizzard
a I had delivered itard flowers has
seven evil exes all of whom you must
defeat in order to date her my God
they're like demonic entities there's
definitely some Jamie huet in this in
the inspiration and you really dated
this guy in middle
school for some reason all the little
jocks wanted me Matthew Patel was the
only non-white non jock boy in
school nothing could beat Matthew's
mystical Powers combined with my brute
strength woof he didn't even get truly
evil until high school and by that time
he lived Far Far Away simmering all's
fair in love and uh war time to fight I
love his super dry H response round one
oh waa it's like an actual Street
[Applause]
Fighter
Zach that
it oh okay I
one I won believe in yourself man you're
on a
league whoa cool yo that was awesome
yeah I really thought that was fantastic
very much so I I love the Contra I mean
I love how it complement and contrasts
with the movie and brings at least the
vague amount I'm familiar with from The
Source material to to life and then
brings its own style on top of that you
know yeah man I thought the animation
was great I love me some animated
properties you know sometimes I look at
our shirts like and I go wow what you
can do when you combine liveaction with
animated counterpart part www. reation
shop.com you get shirts like the shop
Protection Services one right here hey
or the classic movie tickets there you
go or space babies of the G
who influences The influencers Watchman
inspired a soda a soda snip snip dude
the characters on this show would wear
all of these T-shirts they really would
wear all these t-shirts as should you
cuz it is the best way to support the
channel ding my favorite way personally
so thank you to all thank you seriously
to everyone who has bought a shirt
because I think you will feel very I
they're also very comfortable that's
thing I really want to emphasize they're
extremely comfortable shirts and that's
why even before having this shop uh I
would always alternate between the same
kind of shirts because I I prioritize
comfort more than anything else and so
yeah when crafting the shirts you know
you went to factories all over the world
Tred around fac yeah yeah this one
little children in sh yes until we
finally found one in the Himalayas who
made the perfect softness and
stretchability th he just hooked up to
tubes
most of his limbs been retrofitted with
Machinery we've removed a pain sensor in
his brain he's a husk now leading for a
merchandising
husk um on a lighter note on a lighter
note uh I did think this was a very
impressive ethereal experience that had
such a
softer Hue about the whole tone to it
cuz yeah it's like you expect that what
from just knowing the liveaction uh
counterpart part where it's already very
expressive and you're like wow look at
all these like video game and Anime
influences when you're watching the
liveaction one you'd only expect it to
go kind of more Bonkers with it its
expression yet I actually feel like Pace
wise and tonal wise they dialed some of
that back so you actually get a great
balance otherwise this just could have
been an over stimulating experience and
maybe they're gonna get crazier as it
goes I don't really know but what was
fun was watching okay yeah like uh some
stuff we've seen in the live action
because live action's adap adapting the
know it's pretty faithful from what I
understand to the parts of the novels
that it's adapting yeah but you got to
find a structure within a movie yeah and
and and condense things and yeah so
versus here where some stuff might feel
like oh this is coming a lot earlier
than maybe I was expecting it to come
but then it surprises you with oh we're
cutting to this origin of things and
like seeing Gideon very early on or
getting the introduction of the league
it and it's fun seeing the surprises and
how they they sort of let it unfold and
it's like I like watching the
contrasting differences too between
Scott's world where he does feel more
innocent I I think that is one of the
biggest critiques I think of the film
experience is Scott seems like a very
unlikable guy it is a real journey to
him becoming yeah a more soft likable
character yeah it's like the world of
Scott pil it's like he's you like him
because he's funny um but he's very much
immature and needs to come of Age and
and be humble and he seems like an
[__] and maybe he'll become more of
an [__] as it goes but hear him like
this seems like a sweet kid he probably
making some like not so great I mean
he's 23 but he seems like a kid you know
yeah he seems a little more a bit more
innocent in the precariousness that he
finds himself in absolutely um but I
thought this was a a beautiful
experience and I love I love like the
visual language of how it differs in so
many ways than what I was expecting like
there's a lot of these like downward
shots that really emphasize how much
larger than life a lot of this is like a
lot of the camera comes from the below
yeah yeah yeah looking up at various
things and really kind of enhancing
perspectives and stuff like that like
yeah it's funny this is going to be like
the most expanding experience because
once all this visual you know moving
media is done I will finally read you
know the the the stories but but it
makes me want to go read the Manga uh
comic but you know I don't know I don't
know which terminology we accept for
where it was published but yeah but yeah
it really nicely contrasts and I think
you said that thing about the
movie uh I can't remember exactly what
you said but but you you drew a
comparison that that this being
animation almost normalizes some of the
more stylized elements and makes it feel
more breathable anyway and I think that
that some of it is them deliberately
making something that has a more gradual
Airy tone and and just in this format
that's kind of striking to me because I
feel like this is bringing the slice of
liess about this and the sort of malays
of just being in the age group these
people are and and you know the concerns
that they have uh and and that provides
a nice contrast so that when the more
anime specific flourishes and the video
game ones too kick in like they're you
know especially kind of bright and
captivating and I think the movie it's
weird it's like they're both using anime
and video game stylization as part of
the fun of their style but there is
something that does feel different this
iteration of that than the movie and I
feel like where the movie maybe while it
has a lot of anime stuff kind of leans a
bit more video game to me I feel like
this will then lean a bit more anime and
have the video game stuff be a bit more
of a garnish well the other one really
felt the the live action feels still
like an edar right movie yeah this does
not feel like an edar right show it
doesn't feel like a watching yeah but
that but in a good way because you
because right was taking inspiration
from something and then I'm sure like
he's got fingerprints and his DNA in
here still yeah where it's here I'm just
absorbing the world because the writing
feels different the the the execution
feels different and Beyond just hey
we're looking at an animated versus a
liveaction the actual execution of the
story it's it's like when you watch like
a different type of restructuring
placement of events where you choose to
put your focus like even by this point
in in not I I look it's it's
a r it's it's some people might get
annoyed by the amount of like kind of
comparing to the movie but I think
there's going to be millions of millions
of people across the world doing it
right now it's fun
contrasting going it's not the it's not
the movie and I'm mad it's different
when you're like oh this is cool that
they complement and contrast each other
yeah yeah and and like you said it is
actually making me want to read uh the
an the actual Source material because
looking at this I it makes me go oh how
how different is it and and I like
watching these differences unfold like I
think the voice actors are are great so
much to the point where I'm not hearing
a celebrity talking which is what I
thought the characters I thought that's
what it would feel like yeah but I think
that's the nice primer is like you have
this sort of sense memory in the back of
your mind of like I've heard all these
people be these characters before but
then yeah it is so animation feel
different though yeah and I a beautiful
thing and edite isn't involved in this
but I think it is a beautiful thing
about letting you know I'm sure Brian
leoi he's he's you know the credited
he's clearly writing and authoring and
co-writing these and and heavily you
know involved with the authorship and
whoever the directors are as well like I
think it's again it makes me want to go
back to the source material and see how
before I lose this thought I have to
interrupt you I think I know what what
feels different about it I think the
movie the biggest voice about that movie
is the style yes and here
I'm actually really feeling all the
emotional undertones no 100% yeah yeah
yeah it's like there there is that stuff
but the movie is really dazzling you and
it's also like breaking ground for a
bunch of other things quirky and fast
and and but here I'm like oh I'm really
feeling the emotion and I I don't quite
think of that when I think of the movie
yeah you know it just lets you sit in
the space and it takes time for these
interludes and even though it is compact
it's not that long like I think the the
full kind of 27 28 minute experience
allows you to have these interludes that
are quite beautiful like when they they
they're they have things that are
fleeting but very beautiful when they're
in the park together and then you know
that leads up it's like a nice just back
and forth scene and it's very beautiful
but kind of sparse and then they take
the you know space tunnel back to her
house and even the scene between them in
the house yeah you just you kind of feel
the cold and you feel you know the kind
of want for the warmth of the bed and
the warmth of intimacy and yeah it's
like it's fascinating to think of those
things and now I'm curious to to go and
look and see okay so how did the source
material represent this emotionality and
how did it represent the stylized
homages to all the pop culture stuff
that we love well you said warmth
because yeah like saying feeling the
warmth I'm like well actually
emotionally that's I feel the heart I
feel the warmth of these characters more
even though you know some of the more
I'm sure the [__] resides will come
through right now I I I'm I'm endeared
to the characters and not in a way where
I'm just kind of observing and really
enjoying and giddy like I'm it's it's
strange and I thought it would be the
antithesis I thought this would be way
more style like like a fun sugar rush
but what I've left with now is like the
tonality and the and the the atmosphere
and the feeling of it it's weird it's
like this has you even this is more I
this is not a slight whatsoever but in a
way you could kind of just like put this
on and chill to this you and there is
something also too about the combination
of the voices and the animation because
the animation like I am kind of endeared
and impressed by only in that I guess in
you know we live in a world with like
stuff like what if which I really like
uh in lots of ways but you know that's
clearly like computer animated with some
nods to what handrawn stuff looks like
whereas I don't know I guess something
that's produced by Netflix here I'm a
little bit like are they going to go
full on with how the animation
production values are presented and here
I don't know I mean this could all be
done in a computer it probably is but
this has the look and feel at least to
me of something that has that handdrawn
anime tangibility to it and I think the
modern ways in which they you you
mentioned the stereos scoping like the
way they represent depth of field and
and camera glass and stuff like that
that through these stylized things
especially in like a post spiderverse
world is like really lovely and this is
reminding me of like other graphic
novels or other animation not wholesale
but just in the way that they feel kind
of tangible and not like the exact
aesthetic it's nice because this Harkens
to anime has a lot of the you know uh uh
color and Line work that evokes that but
this also has the benefit of the book's
art style which is inspired by that but
is also kind of adapting that you know
kind of colliding it I feel like I don't
know exactly but I feel like the anime
is Brian Le Ali like is in America right
like he's not like in Japan I don't know
but I always he sounds Japanese it's it
it feels like well you know he's he's he
sounds like a guy who comes from a mixed
background and certainly this is about
you know like Canadians hanging out in
Canada so there there feels like a kind
of melding of traditions in terms of the
animation that is certainly skewing way
more anime but yeah it has something
that's that seems concerned with the art
being kind of beautiful and ethereal
also well I I felt like there was a
little bit more in the live action a
little bit more entitlement and snobbery
in some of their characters and here
what I thought was neat is talk about
the characters me sound like I don't
like they're a little more edgy yeah um
but there a bit more of a cnic cynicism
to the approach of the characters I
would say um and and the world of the
characters and that and that supports
the whip crack tone yeah yeah yeah the
contrast of that but the what was cool
about the structure here of introducing
the league he you need that for a show
cuz like in the movie it's it's like a
surprise like whoa this came out of
nowhere and it's a surprise and then the
action happens you're like what the hell
like this is and it's supposed to have
that effect and I think what was
different about the vibe here is a not
going through knives Chow uh so early on
yeah and and letting you just get so
acquainted with like man he's a dick in
this relationship and so you're just
you're just connected to the romance to
henra Ramona and then having the
introduction of the villains or the
tease of them which does feel like anime
demonic kind of villainy with the evil
and the eyes and stuff but what's really
cool about that is then you have a
threat to the relationship yeah as
opposed to just a fun game you're going
to go through well yeah you've got the
compounding of like oh the stakes are
already high cuz they're both here and
now we're going to get multiple reveals
you know because her Ramona's pass is
going to be revealed to some extent and
also I mean you know Scott is Small
Change on the floor right now so you
know that kniv is gonna have something
to say about that I didn't think we'd
have so much to say about the first
episode I thought we'd have to like kind
of settle with it but hey we got uh
seven more of these to go through uh but
I'm I'm on board for the journey man I'm
on board for the journey uh that took me
by surprise in a way I really wasn't
expecting yeah this this this like I
thought it was just going to be like fun
this fed me more than like you know like
I'm already excited and I'm already like
inclined towards liking it and this
engaged me well beyond that in ways I
wasn't expecting it to along with all
the the stuff I understand to be the
earmarks of this so like I'm I'm just
surprised that yeah it's like especially
because Netflix is getting into making
more anime I'm like this actually gives
me a lot of Hope for that % th% feels
really crafted and that's beautiful all
right guys well what did you think about
this um I'm sure you guys are already
done with the series if you're watching
this reaction uh but let us know your
thoughts down in the comments and uh
keep a lookout for our reaction to uh
episode dose uh we'll try to get these
out every other day hopefully we have
holidays coming up so please be patient
if we uh fall behind a little bit on
schedule but thank you so much we'll
talk with you all
[Music]
soon